hi this is Jeff's the director of the
Great Race and we're continuing our
series of how-to videos and today we're
going to talk about making up time now
like everything in the great race you
need to keep it simple everybody knows
the ki SS rule and that really does
apply to the great race and if you're
trying to make up lost time again
don't panic it happens to everybody and
if you worry too much about one being
one second off on something there my one
second late and worry about it too much
and you miss the next sign you're gonna
be more than one second late you're
gonna be thirty seconds later five
minutes late so keep it simple and don't
worry about the small things especially
early on have fun your first year don't
worry about the small things now if
you're 30 seconds late and you know it
and you want to make up that thirty
seconds there's a simple way to do it
and it's called the ten percent rule and
the way I like to think about it is I
have to make up thirty seconds so I can
make up for every 10 seconds of rallying
if I go 10% over the prescribed speed
for every ten seconds I can make it one
second so in a minute at ten percent
over I can make up six seconds now
what's ten percent over well let's say
the prescribed speed is 40 miles per
hour and I want to make up my 30 seconds
well first 10% over of 40 miles an hour
is 44 miles per hour 10% over at 35
miles per hour is 38 and a half miles
per hour
you take let's go back to the 40 example
4 to 10 percent of the 40 is 4 seconds
so yeah that 4
seconds to the 40 and you get 44 so if
you drive 44 miles per hour while
everyone else is driving 40 miles per
hour you will increase your place on the
course by one second every 10 seconds or
by 6 seconds every minute so if I'm do
40 and 4 miles per hour for 1 minute
I've made up 6 seconds and the way we
like to do it when we're routing is to
keep up with that as we go because
sometimes you won't be able get all 30
seconds made up all at one time it may
be in chunks so if I can get 1 minute in
that's 6 seconds if I can get another
minute in that's 12 seconds and so on
until you've made up the entire 30
seconds of time now as you get a little
more comfortable with it and it's in a
big chunk like that you may choose to do
20% over again you take 20% of the
prescribed speed that's 40 miles per
hour that would be 8 you would do 48
miles an hour then now you're making up
12 seconds for every minute that you're
liked now don't forget that you have to
as you're doing this speed extra speed
you have to continue watching for the
signs so you're doing 2 things you're
going faster then you're prescribed to
go you're doing 44 instead of 40 but you
also have to keep watching for the signs
because some of the signs mean a new
instruction which might mean a new new
speed what I would do is come off of
that speed at the knee of the speed
you're doing it didn't sign get adjusted
to the new speed let's say it's a curve
warning sign and now he's supposed to be
doing 35 instead of the 40 that you were
doing a minute ago go ahead and come off
of that and got to calculate how much
time you did make up now you're doing 35
get comfortable then go 10% over again
that's 38 and a half and continue to
knock off all this time that you need to
gain now another way to do this is that
stop signs now a lot of veterans don't
like to do this because they're afraid
of a checkpoint again as a rookie or
somebody's that's only done the race a
couple of years if that's more
comfortable for you that's a that's a
good way to do it because you can knock
off bigger chunks at stop signs
especially if you know that there's a
stop sign coming up if there's stop sign
coming up and you're doing 40 miles an
hour and you're gonna stop at that stop
sign for 10 seconds and you stop for one
you've made up nine seconds right there
at that stop sign so you can also
eliminate big chunks at stop signs if
you get caught by a checkpoint that's
the way it goes that's why we have what
we call the throw out legs where you can
throw out as a rookie or a sports when
you can throw out your 5 worst legs on
the entire nine day event one last piece
of advice do not try to make up time in
a timed interval if you're doing a
certain speed and it tells you to do 30
miles an hour for seven minutes and
you're using the stopwatch to do that do
not make up time during that time it
will mess up what you're already doing